نعم صباح الخير من برج حمود هذه المنطقه
التي تشتهر باصواتها الشعبيه وبكسره مشاغل
الذهب فيها الا ان خلف طرقتها الرئيسيه
يعني تنطوي احياء وشوارع شديده الفقر الا
انه مش حمود تحولت الى واحه فنيه بمشاركه
الاهالي وبفضل جمعيه المحليه نطلع على
المزيد مع ضيف سامح الحلواني سامح اتى من
مصر خصيصا وشارك الجمعيه في هذه النشاطات
اليوم سامح انتم تحرصون على يعني من خلال
الفن والثقافه احداث لو فرق بسيط وتغيير
يعني في احوال الناس هناك خبرنا اكثر
من مستوى الحياه وجودتها من خلال الفن
والاداب بيكون عبر ان احنا بنختار مكان
ممكن يكون في الشارع اماكن مهمله او
بالزباله او حاجات زي كده ونحاول مع اهالي
المنطقه بتشاركهم معنا ان احنا ننظفها
وبعد كده تتحول وتتجمل وتبقى مكان صالح
انها تكون بابلي اكسبريس مساحه عامه للناس
تمارس فيها لونها ويومها وتعيش فيها بشكل
جيد حتى اكثر من الاول يعني ده اللي
بنتمناه من خلال
الفرحه كبيره فيها بطاله الا انه مثل ما
قلت ما في عندنا مساحه عامه اليوم انت
عملت خبراتك من من مصر
الى والترمين والرسم على على الحيطان
وتجميل الاماكن والفنون في الشارع كيف
لمست هل هناك فرق يعني بين الناس بين هون
وهنيك اهل في قواسم مشتركه بين البلدين
بين الشعبين خصوصا انا عم نحكي بالاماكن
الاقل الحافظه
بس انا المهم بالنسبه لي هنا في برج حمود
برج حمود اساسا هي مكان فني تاريخيا يمكن
الظروف والاقتصاد ادى الوضع سيء حاليا لكن
اعتقد ان الامل موجود جدا من خلال
الحرفيين والفنانين الموجودين في المنطقه
ان هم بيحدثوا تغيير ويكون من وراء ده
داخل اقتصادي هايل لكل البلد واعتقد ان
الفن والفنانين هم القادرين على احداث
التغيير ده او تحسين مستوى الحياه ده او
البدايه منه ويكون هم الطريق الاخضر
كيف اثر على حياته والله يعني انا مش
هاقول التاثير لا انا هاقول التفاعل اساسا
والتاثير ده ليكن بعد كده بيبان مع الزمن
لكن لما الاقي الناس من اول لحظه بكل فئات
العمر بتشارك في النظافه وفي المتابعه ثم
التجميل ثم الرسم باصرار وطلب كل يوم
بيجيء لي الطلبه تعال لون عندنا تعال
عندنا تعالوا بيعملوا قدامي نفسهم ده انا
يعني بيتهيا لي ده اكثر يعني دليل على مش
بس تغيير على ان فعلا ان الناس فيها امل
بس محتاجه اللي يحركها واللي يرشدها
الفكره فنيه جميله تجمعهم مع بعض بدل ما
هم متخانقين طوائف وكوره ههه يعني محتاجين
نتجمع ونعمل حاجه مع بعض بالشكل همم جماعي
لطيف واعتقد ده اللي بنحاول نعملهم من
خلال جمعتنا احنا اليوم الى جانب
الجداريات
كمان حرسته انكم تنشروها خبرني اكثر
وازاي ان احنا بنشارك او بنخلي الشباب
والناس اللي عندها ابداع او عندها موهبه
فنيه انها تشارك اولا في انتاج افلام عن
حياتهم وعن يومياتهم وعن الحرف اللي
بينتبوها بشكل او باخر وهنا دي وجهه نظري
فيها ان احنا نقدر نشوف الواقع من خلال
صحابه مش من فيلم ميكر اللي هم هيعمله فدي
له الورشه دي كانت بتقدم ده وفي ورشه
ثانيه مع شباب برده نعمله مسرحيات في
الشارع وده عرضنا منهم اول عرض من اسبوعين
تقريبا في المنطقه اللي انتم شفتوها
وتلونت هناك ده كان عرض في الشارع وده كان
عليه اقبال انا شخصيا كنت همم كنت خائف من
ده لكن اللي حصل بالعكس تماما الناس تشارك
وحبت وطلبه المزيد مهمه وصلتهم رساله
العرض دي كانت جميله
يعني حياتهم كانت ماده تسمي لهيك عروضات
لهيك همم اكيد في افكار متاقطه طبعا من
دوت لها علاقه بالهجره لها علاقه بالحلم
بالسفر بره ليه علاقه بالوضع السيء
الموجود الاقتصادي ولكن العرض والناس كانت
عندها امل فين بكره اعتقد ده ال- اا دي
الرساله اللي احنا بنحاول نوجهها من خلال
الفن ان يكون في امل لبكره افضل يعني
اليوم نحن كمان
مشهوره يعني همم
يعني نقدر نقول ده مركز لبناني الحرفي لكن
لبنان همم وده نتيجه البحث الفني اللي انا
عملته في كل ارجاء لبنان في كل منطقه في
لبنان في حرف مستوطنه وشكل قوي جدا
وموجوده يمكن سلاسل التوليد بتاعتها
والخامات يكون في ازمه نتيجه الدولار
والاستيراد ولكن الحرفيين وهم دول اهم
عنصر في الحرف موجودين كفاءه عاليه وعندهم
استعداد يتطور يعني وفي امل فيهم كبير
وفيهم شباب ودي حاجه كويسه بنتمنى ان احنا
نقدر نساعدها اكتر وندعمها بحيث انها تكون
قادره انها تكون يعني قاطره التحسين الوضع
في لبنان في الوقت اللي جايه
على هذا الامل نعود اليكم الى الاستوديو